hello everyone and welcome to another
one of those games that uh really show
us how unforgiving chess is and that you
can't relax even for a single second
otherwise you're gonna
uh well just just lose the game even
though you've had a perfectly fine
position for for an hour for two hours
for five hours uh if you if you make
that one little little mistake uh then
uh your entire position collapses it is
round four uh we're still going to show
again from round five but this is the
one i wanted to show from round four uh
wesley so versus yanni pognashin of the
super bet chess classic uh let's check
it out the game follows known theory for
some 21 move so that's uh there's that
but the good part comes after that so
let's just um get to that point so here
wesley opens with knight to f3 that at
the opening we have d5 at d for knight
to f6 and now c4 we have e6 so we've
transposed into the queens again by
decline and g3 and now shifting into the
catalan we have bishop to e7 bishop to
g2 both players castle and now d
captures on c4 so this is the
the
meanest
of the main
queen to c2 we have b5 now defending the
c4 pawn and of course we undermine
black's overextended pawn structure here
bishop to b7 a captures on b5 and a6 so
again nothing new here this has been
played many many times b captures knight
captures and now finally queen captures
on c4 white wins back the pawn
or rather white is up upon so here
bishop to d5 attacking the queen queen
to c3 and now pawn to c5 getting rid of
the backwards c pawn and then black will
have a lot of development then so for
the price of one pawn uh black is um
more developed for the moment so bishop
to e3 uh we have knight to e4 attacking
the queen here and now queen back to e1
we have knights to b4 uh and rook
captures an a8 we have queen captures an
a8 and knight to c3 knight captures b
captures attacking the knight here
knight to c to attacking the queen and
the bishop queen d2 knight captures and
queen characters c capture sunday for c
capture sunday for in the rook to d8 so
quite a capture fest we've had here and
it's now move 20 still known theory
queen to f4 by wesley and now there is a
game uh that was played like a month or
two months ago in slovenia in the
european individual championship between
marty rosen and gabrielescu uh where
queen the a4 was played amaterosan was
able to win that game but here we have
h6 by nipple and it is now as of move 21
that we have a completely new game and
it was h6 is quite an improvement to
governor lesko's queen to a4 it is one
of the engine's top top choices so this
is where a game truly begins and now
it's westley to play he starts with e3
and once the bishop moves you want more
protection for that d4 pawn and you have
a light square bishop makes sense you
want to put your pawns on on dark
squares here bishop to d6 uh getting the
bishop to a more active square attacking
the queen queen h4 now you have to be
careful if you move the queen you're
gonna lose the rook uh bishop to b4 and
now queen to g4 uh and now well you
could wait white will probably at some
point play knight stage four because you
have to trade the lights where bishops
um at the knight can't really move
anywhere you're just going to lose the
bishop here so nepal doesn't even wait
for this he just trades bishop for night
he says
i'd rather have your knight than your
bishop because your bishop will not be
all that useful my only weakness here in
the camp is the f7 pawn and the knight
can attack this the bishop cannot attack
this so here bishop captures an f3
bishop captures and queen to a5 now uh
we have rook to b1 by wesley now comes
the bishop back to d6 and here h4 now
grabbing more space here on the king
side rook to b8 offering a rook trade
and here wesley says thank you very much
this allows me to at least play
something he plays rook captures on b8
bishop captures and now this very tricky
d5 move uh point being that if e
captures on d5 queen c8 check picks up
the bishop on c8
on b8 so instead after d5 we have queen
to a1 with check
king to g2 and queen to e5 now uh and
now okay you could play the d captures
on e6 but here nipple will just capture
and if you trade queens this is a draw
yes wesley is up a pawn but his bishops
of opposite colors uh bishop
of opposite color not much to look for
here so after queen e5 we have queen to
c4
and now bishop to d6 again you have to
prevent uh queen c8 or followed by this
trick okay for the moment queen guards
the b8 square but
better save than sorry so d captures on
e6 queen captures and now bishop to d5
so uh remember a couple of moves ago uh
we said that we have a bishops of
opposite color game here with queens on
the board and you can see that the f2
pawn uh can be attacked by the dark
square bishop but it's very unlikely you
have to put your bishop on e1 to attack
the spawn we don't see that happening
and it was very unlikely for wesley to
get a grab hold of the f7 pawn but as
you can see allowing uh
that d5 move also allowed now this queen
bishop battery uh to put pressure on the
f7 pawn at least so queen d7 nipple now
has to put keep an eye on the f7 pawn h5
and now uh queen to f5 we have queen to
c6 attacking the bishop and bishop to f8
so how can uh wesley push for for more
than a draw here well we have bishop to
f3 queen to e6 again nepal offers a
queen trade queen to a8 you have to
decline once you trade queens it's it's
a draw queen to e5 um
and now bishop to g4 we have queen to f6
bishop back to d1 queen to f5 putting
pressure on the h5 pawn but it doesn't
matter the bishop from d1 nicely defends
this queen to b7 and now queen to e5
with bishop to e2 now comes queen back
to f5 bishop to f3 queen to e5 nipple
just moves the queen back and forth says
all right this is the draw
bishop to g4 and queen back to g5 now
attacking the bishop queen to f3
uh and here you could repeat with queen
to f6 nothing happens but nipple i guess
he got bored uh plays g6 uh it does it
does change the structure a little bit
but it doesn't matter you're still gonna
put the bishop on g7 and the light
square bishop can't to do all that much
about this so h characters queen
captures bishop to f5 and queen f6 so
not a lot for for wesley to do here
queen to d5 and queen to d6 again
offering a queen trade queen to c4 queen
to be for now nepo is forcing a queen
trade almost uh but obviously of course
declines queen e2 we have queen b7 check
king h2 and bishop to g7 now uh we have
bishop back to d3 and the queen to d5 so
even if you somehow get your queen all
the way to h7 it's still nothing so
there's really
not nothing you can do here to to push
for for uh advantage but you can of
course uh try there's always this e4
idea maybe you can start pushing those
pawns and obviously of course before
agreeing to a draw we'll try at least
that so here bishop c4 again attacking
the queen queen e4 we have bishop back
to b3 and queen to f5 now you have to be
careful the f2 pawn might become weak if
the queen moves so e for now advancing
the pawn and this is very important as
no captures have been made for quite a
while we have to make a pawn move
otherwise we might get to a draw by a 50
move rule so queen to f6 we have king to
g2 now the queen can move so you don't
lose the f2 pawn queen to b6 attacking
the bishop and the bishop to d5 with uh
and uh here comes the uh the move here
and nipple has to continue very
carefully he he needs to play queen to
g6 and now the game continues okay
wesley does have pressure he will open
up the position this pawn will come to
e6 for example e5 but after bishop to f8
and d6 it's not that big of a deal f
captures the bishop captures king h7 and
you will be you you will be okay here if
you try something like queen e5 to trap
a black's queen uh we're just gonna play
bishop g7 attack the white queen and if
queen d5 still threatening this just
queen to e8
and you don't have to worry about this
if queen f5 check we're going to play
king to h8 and you do control a lot of
squares but you you there's no way for
you to actually control the dark square
so this is just a draw however after
this bishop to d5 move nipple played the
only move pretty much that loses the
game uh okay you could play some like
queen captures on f2 but that would be
silly never played uh a bush to d4 and
now wesley has a brilliant brilliant
move that
really
makes it impossible for nepal to hold
the position so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this idea for
wesley while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
pawn to e5 that's the good stuff now the
bishop that was so conveniently
defending all of the dark squares from
g7
no longer has access to g7 and that's uh
that's a big problem how can how can you
play this uh well you could try
something like king to f8 and this is in
fact the strongest move uh but it's
still not gonna be easy we're gonna play
queen to e4 now uh what what what can
you play uh
if you play something like bishop
captures an f2 we're going to play queen
to f5 and now we're attacking the bishop
and the df7 square so we're threatening
checkmate and we're also threatening to
pick up the bishop so that's out of the
question and another thing you can do is
move something like queen to c5 but now
we execute e6 and after captures and
captures this will be
very very very difficult to hold because
uh well it's just that the black king is
wide open and we still have the f-pawn
we can push this it's uh
in a practical game you are not
defending this with absolute perfect
play maybe it's a draw but very unlikely
that um
you could you could hold this however
nipple played queen to g6 and now it is
completely winning for wesley here
nipple missed the one very very tricky
idea uh so pause the video once again
and try to find this uh instant win uh
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on sporting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
the shop captures on f7 that's the good
stuff this is what wesley played and he
was in this position on move 58 that the
anybody should resign the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so uh
very interesting how 30 30 moves ago we
said that no no way white is reaching
the f7 pawn and no way black is reaching
the f2 pawn and here you can see that
black is attacking the f2 pawn and the
wesley is attacking the f7 pawn but okay
it's because wesley wanted it to be so
if he didn't start advancing the pawn
here then of course that would not
happen but here you resign because uh
what what can you play uh after bishop
captures an f7 uh if you capture with
the queen and you must capture a bishop
otherwise you're just gonna lose the
queen so if you play queen captures on
f7 then queen g4 check picks up the
bishop and it doesn't matter what you
play because now you are up two points
and of course two pawns is completely
two pawns up is completely winning uh in
an end game with or without the queens
on the board and if you don't capture
with the queen if you capture with the
king then we have this queen to see for
check again picking up the bishop and
again pretty much getting the exact same
end game of course this will be
completely winning and jan knows this so
after bishop captures an f7 he resigned
the game
so really really incredible stuff by
wesley uh winning this uh and i will i
promise i will show you the standings so
now after five rounds of this uh
wonderful tournament uh these are the
standings as you can see uh wesley uh
leading the tournament with three and a
half points uh followed by lavon ariana
and maxime bashar al-agrav and uh bogdan
daniel dak with three points with two
and a half we have fabiana karwana and
janiponishi two points alireza furuji
and richard rapport uh in the linear
dominguez and with one and a half points
shakhtar mamadarov who is definitely not
uh having the greatest tournament and
unfortunately for him the next video we
are showing is probably his game against
fabi but that's just the way it is uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and really uh congratulations
to everyone who spotted both of the
positive video moments i would like to
wish a very happy birthday to rodolf
nrclb
and i would like to thank claudio
bravely and alessandro bossie uh yoga
spot key donating because it is the
strongest move uh perez sulbachen and
tariq allah uh uh aldol for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh the coverage of
this wonderful event until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day